nous sommes avec nadim andraos vice
président exécutif de fb france bonjour
bonjour alors avant de parler de
l'implantation de votre nouveau site
dans lequel on se trouve parlant de
l'actualité le coronavirus et ses
conséquences sur l'économie mondiale
vous êtes une multinationale vous est
implanté dans l'ensemble des continents
du monde entier quelles sont les
conséquences directes que vous ressentez
aujourd'hui très bien on a lancé déjà un
task force au niveau international on a
un point régulier chaque matin à 8
heures on a les collègues du chine qui
intervient nous donner leurs
informations
jusqu'à maintenant on a toujours on n'a
pas arrêté la production en chine mais
certainement il faut respecter les
consignes mesurer les températures trois
fois par jour ils sont déjà à ce niveau
là bas et si ici on dépasse les
transfère 2002 la légion elle sombre à
deux doigts de rentrer au site
là on arrive encore à maintenir la
production en chine et en france vous
voyez on continue la production en
france pas encore d'impact pas pour le
moment non vous me mettez vous avez mis
en en place les mesures justes du
gouvernement signe de convenants talent
et on va voir ce qui nous attend d'ici à
la semaine prochaine ça a évolué
rapidement alors fb france est une
multinationale spécialisée dans
l'ingénierie dans la recherche et
développement de l'industrie du
transport
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer en
quoi ça consiste donc les racines venait
de développement de la combustion en
1978 et ça évolue rapidement d'une
manière qu'aujourd'hui pour faire face
aux enjeux environnementaux et
politiques
on a avancé tu peux nos développements
on a renforcé nos activités du point du
vue ingénierie du véhicule
tout ce qui est électrification de la
chaîne de traction complète tout ce qui
est en plus véhicules connectés et
véhicule autonome vous lancer ce site le
centre de développement de la mobilité
du futur
qu'est ce qui va se passer ici donc nos
activités c'est d'accompagner les
constructeurs se tout ce qui est
traction électrique et là ici on mesure
tous leurs batteries
dans ce dernier on commence par les
mesures des cellules après les packs et
les modules et les pâques au pied
deux personnes vont travailler ici donc
sur ce bâtiment là on est à peu près une
douzaine de personnes ça fait déjà cinq
jusque 5 ans qu'on a commencé cette
activité
au début elle était au centre au milieu
de notre bâtiment mais certainement il
faut respecter certaines normes c'est
pour ça on a déménagé tout ici on a
presque multiplié par dix la capacité
avant nous étions assez lieu dans les
passes et a souri cellule pour
accompagner le développement rapide de
la rectification
en france oui vous parlez de cinq ans
parce que vous êtes implantée à trappes
depuis 2000 15 ans et demi 15 voilà donc
là le groupe a démarré ses activités en
france en 2005 et en 2015 on a racheté
la boîte d2t dans le temps et on évolue
rapidement donc on est presque à une
croissance de 20% annuel depuis 2015
c'est un territoire stratégique je
suppose parce que on voit beaucoup
d'acteurs de l'automobile présent est
installé sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines
c'est c'est un endroit vraiment
stratégique nous avons le technocentre
de renault qui est à côté nous avons
peugeot implantée à carrières sous
poissy il ya d autres encore
fournisseurs qui sont dans le coin
donc c'est un point vraiment stratégique
pour nous concrètement vous travaillez
comment avec le techno semble par
exemple parce que c'est vraiment ce
alors que le coeur de leur activité
c'est la recherche et développement
autour du véhicule
voilà on les accompagne dans tous ce
domaine je suis pas rentré en détail au
delà de ça désolé c'est confidentiel
c'est ça oui c'est clairement comment
vous travaillez finalement c'est vous
vous faites quoi vous fait de
l'accompagnement vous allez mettre en
place des systèmes pour tester des
prototypes comment ça se passe donc on
peut mettre des systèmes quand vous
venez de le dire mais en plus on peut au
delà de ça même développé des prototypes
pour eux quel regard vous avez sur la
mobilité du futur vous donc certainement
il faut l'accompagner c'est une
évolution qui est rapide
actuellement on a passé dans les étapes
de l'hybride on va passer partir à
passer après auckland in hybrid et se
rapprocher à fur à mesure de tout ce qui
est l édification de la chaîne de
traction
c'est un nouveau site une nouvelle
implantation c'est quoi la stratégie
qu'il ya derrière
quelle stratégie a derrière la stratégie
économique la stratégie de l'entreprise
avec ce nouveau site avec ce nouveau si
c'est certainement l'accompagnement
de la transition au niveau de la chaîne
de traction et certainement on va le
développer à fur et à mesure c'est ce
que vous voyez c'est juste la partie qui
élit héros au testing des batteries mais
il ya encore le moteur électrique tout
ce qui est ou totaux de yack seul ça
c'est dans l'autre bâtiment on va pas
parler aujourd'hui
quel avenir quelles sont les
perspectives d'avenir de développement
de ff france donc comme j'ai dis donc
depuis 2015 on est en croissance à peu
près de 20% lendemain % annuels on va le
maintenir à ce niveau et être toujours
présent sur ce secteur
nadim andros merci beaucoup merci bien
vous vice président exécutif de f levé
france